[Music]
alright man in black today yes season
two finally upon us
yes finally when you got your hands on
that first script what was your reaction
well it's almost like it's like
Christmas morning I mean you're holding
the present in your hand you almost
don't want to open it like what could
this be I don't want to read it because
then it will be that but that is always
great when you get through it I could
never have conceived of that so I always
call Evan beforehand like did you get
scripted you can see I got the script
when you're gonna read it I want to read
it when you're reading it and they'll
call each other afterwards
so we're fans first on this show we
thrilled to get up and go to work every
day on this and and not know where the
hell we're going or what the hell we're
doing
you know we I've I've I've surrendered
to there's a lot of surrender on this
kind of got to give up you're a certain
degree of power just go hey I'm going to
you know let go sort of see where this
all is taking me and there's a real
great feeling of satisfaction when
you're in the hands of Jonah and Lisa
and their world that they're creating
it's anyway so yeah it's we always Evan
and I well let's give each other a ring
after we read a script and oh my god
where do we pick up with Teddy so the
last season we left him basically kind
of waking up and he was one of the last
hosts to realize that he was a host and
and all that that entailed and
unfortunately for him his you know Evan
and Tandy were respectively
Dolores and Maeve had a whole season to
sort of incremental e some reached that
level of sentience and Teddy's it was
the last couple of episodes but once he
fully had his eyes open you know
for real for the first time it shots
rang out and it was the you know the
floodgates opened and the beginning of a
revolution essentially so he's now awake
being born into this war that's so it's
a tough time for him and I think he's
kind of like Dolores what are we doing
what what what what's going on yeah yeah
I'll follow you yeah yeah sure okay
where are we going what are we doing so
it's it's a really interesting thing as
an actor to play because you're dealing
with being born into ten to
consciousness for the first time but
also like certain survived having to
survive right
yeah heaven was saying it's interesting
to watch Teddy and Dolores his love
story whether we can even call it a love
story because they're programmed or
maybe they're not in this time of war
unfold they're getting to learn about
themselves and each other right well all
the world is calling yeah because
they're now in a place where they have
shed their programmed identity and get
to choose their own identity and what is
that and what do you stand for and how
hell-bent on revenge are you or what
where is the do you still have a code of
morality decency
when the stakes are high and it's about
surviving so yes I think there is
residual actually the word trace decay
which is one of the titles of one of the
episodes which is lingering memories or
thoughts after something was programmed
or an experience so I think there is
code of teddys that he's retained you
know and a lot of that is his loyalty
and his allegiance and his love
affection for Dolores but that's not to
say that that doesn't get challenged
this season you know I think that
they're going through a considerable
phase of growth and we'll see where they
go what was your number one question
left over from season one I mean they're
still yeah there's still pieces I'm kind
of like I guess my big questions are a
man where the hell is going like where
are we going
I can kind of feel like with the rest of
the audience
where we're going obviously have read
season two so I know that what what
what's going to unfold there but big
picture endgame stuff I just it's a
guessing game every day I mean it's like
you know every day we go to set and me
and Jeffry or mean Tandy or Evan will go
like okay what do you think is gonna
happen what do you think is gonna happen
by the end of the season we're like ah
so-and-so is right on it sellin sellers
right unless you were totally wrong on
that no dick enough so there's there's
this great kind of delicious wonderful
questions of all of us trying to figure
out you know what where we're going
what's going on yeah and and and Jonah
and Lisa and all the you know
brilliantly talented writers they've got
all this mapped out this isn't like a
halo skier Ice Show picked up and then
we'll figure it out they know you know
this thing goes for ten seasons they
know exactly how it's gonna end where
it's gonna go last year your but
everybody was talking about it what is
going to be the campus everybody's gonna
be talking about it
thing about season two so i'm ii assumed
that the can't-miss everyone talks about
thing about season one was my bike yeah
okay cool that's a hard thing to answer
because then I have to get into
specifics and I can't really maybe just
maybe one word yeah I don't know I mean
yeah revolution I guess I know that's a
big one but yeah I'll take resolution
balances with that
[Music]